hasta ahora ya les he dado dos
definiciones de la variable de estado
entropía ese se refiere a la entropía y
la definición termodinámica decía que el
cambio en la entropía era igual al calor
entre la temperatura verdad ok
así que obviamente si la temperatura
está cambiando bueno al agregar el calor
tenemos que hacer un poquito de cálculo
y cuando lo vemos desde el punto de
vista matemático o estadístico
combinatorio en realidad esto
esencialmente nos dice que la entropía
es igual a alguna constante por el
logaritmo natural del número de estados
que el sistema puede tomar y en este
caso cuando todos los estados son
igualmente probables que es bastante
cómodo para trabajar tenemos si tenemos
un montón pero un montón de moléculas en
realidad tenemos muchísimos más estados
posibles ok entonces no vamos a
preocuparnos ahorita cuando haya
distintas probabilidades simplemente
vamos a introducirnos al tema de la
segunda ley de la termodinámica
segunda ley
y la segunda ley dice esto que es
bastante simple pero explica un montón
de fenómenos nos dice que el cambio el
cambio en la entropía el cambio la
entropía del universo
en la entropía del universo cuando en un
proceso se lleva a cabo va a ser siempre
mayor o igual que cero así que esto nos
dice que cuando cualquier cosa que
ocurre en el universo el efecto neto es
que hay más entropía en el en el
universo mismo y esto parece ser
bastante profundo y de hecho lo es así
que vamos a aplicarlo a algunas cositas
vamos a ver cómo explica y cómo da
sentido a algunos este fenómenos digamos
por ejemplo que tengo dos depósitos uno
que tiene temperatura de 1
porque digamos un depósito de calor pues
de alta temperatura y digamos que tengo
un té 2 que es un depósito frío ahora ya
sabemos de la experiencia que pasa
cuando tengo por ejemplo una taza de
agua y le echo un vidrio perdón que lo
pongo al lado de un vaso con con agua
fría no entonces esencialmente es lo que
estamos haciendo por ejemplo en este
caso simplemente la parte caliente se va
a transferir hacia la parte fría con una
un calor q ok no lo vemos todos los días
realmente que el calor vaya realmente
del punto más caliente al al más frío
pero si pongo un cubo de hielo y le
pongo en una taza con té hirviendo vas a
ver que ambos llegan a una misma
temperatura que esencialmente estamos
diciendo que la parte caliente lcd calor
la parte fría entonces esto por supuesto
sólo lo estamos pensando desde forma
teórica en un digamos depósitos
infinitos no no creo que existan estos
en la naturaleza pero vamos a ver qué
nos dice la segunda ley de la
termodinámica respecto a que esto
debería ocurrir qué es lo que está
pasando aquí cuál es el cambio neto en
la entropía para tf1 así que la segunda
ley de la termodinámica dice que el
cambio en la entropía del universo es
mayor o igual que cero pero en este caso
es igual al cambio la entropía
dt uno más el cambio en la estropeada
bueno quizás no debería llamarle t uno
porque tengo uno es una temperatura
déjenme llamarle solo
sólo uno ok que este es el sistema 1 el
caliente y más el cambio en la entropía
del sistema 2 que es el frío así que
cuál es el cambio en la entropía del
sistema 1 bueno esto pierde calor 1
pierde calor a una temperatura de 1
entonces esto es menos porque pierde
calor menos q sobre de 1 que es nuestra
temperatura alta y cuando analizamos el
cambio en la entropía para el sistema 2
tenemos que éste gana cubo de calor
sobre t 2 verdad entonces este es el
cambio la entropía del sistema 2 el
primero pierde calor que se lo cede al
segundo entonces por eso él explica los
signos pero bueno esto la pregunta es
esto va a ser mayor o igual que 0 y
vamos a pensar un poquito de esto si yo
divido déjenme déjenme reescribir esto
esto es igual a q sobre t 2 - - - curso
brete uno solo reacomodo de esto verdad
ahora cual número es más grande de 2 o t
1 bueno tengo uno es más grande porque
supusimos que era caliente verdad
uno es más grande ahora si tengo un
número más grande de hecho es más grande
que te dos okay comparado con esto que
uno es más grande que te dos y como
tenemos el mismo numerador en ambos
casos entonces por ejemplo si yo tuviera
un medio un medio ajá y le restó un
tercio bueno va a ser mayor que cero
verdad porque si estamos dividiendo
entre un número más grande vamos a tener
un número más pequeño es decir por
ejemplo si partimos un pastel en un
número cada vez más grande de pedazos
pues tenemos más una fracción más chica
del pastel verdad así que este número
esta diferencia va a ser mayor o igual
que cero eso nos dice la segunda ley de
la termodinámica y verifique esta
observación que vemos en el mundo real
que que la temperatura más alta va a va
a ser que el calor fluya del más alto al
más bajo así que tú podrías decir oye yo
tengo un ejemplo un caso en donde tú es
esta afirmación está mal por ejemplo si
pongo un aire
aire acondicionado en un cuarto digamos
que este es el cuarto este de la
izquierda y a la derecha está el
exterior lo que dices es bueno mira el
aire acondicionado hace esto el el
cuarto ya está frío ya afuera está muy
caliente pero lo que hace el aire
acondicionado es que hace esto todavía
más frío y hace que el exterior se haga
más caliente entonces el calor q va en
esta dirección toma calor del cuarto
frío y lo es
lo manda afuera al al exterior caliente
entonces si tú demostraros que esto
fuera cierto ya te ganarías el premio
nobel pero tengo que decirte algo que
estás olvidando un pequeño hecho el aire
acondicionado por dentro tiene cierto
tipo de compresor una máquina que está
activamente haciendo esto está poniendo
a trabajar a realizar trabajo más bien y
esta máquina de aquí que lo estoy
poniendo con magenta está cediendo calor
también hacia el exterior un cubo
digamos que le voy a poner
de la máquina que es del calor que
expide la máquina así que si queremos
ver el total de entropía creada por este
este pequeño universo entonces
tendríamos que el cambio dentro piensa
el cambio de la entropía del cuarto frío
ok del cuarto frío más el cambio de la
entropía para el exterior aunque más el
cambio la entropía del exterior
ok entonces tú podrías decir este cambio
en la entropía para el cuarto déjenme
ver
el cuarto está digamos
nos estaba cediendo cierto calor que a
una temperatura de 1
esto es un menos verdad porque lo está
accediendo y este exterior va a recibir
este calor pero está a una temperatura
de 2
este número de aquí t 2 es mucho más
grande que el de 1 verdad porque estamos
suponiendo que hace calor afuera así que
si ves solo esto dirías bueno esto es
negativo y esto como que contradice la
segunda ley de la termodinámica pero no
porque no hemos agregado el calor que
genera la máquina así que hay que
agregar el calor que genera la máquina
entre la temperatura del exterior y
bueno no tengo los números precisos pero
yo te puedo garantizar que este calor
que genera la máquina siempre debe ser
tal que toda esta expresión nos dé mayor
igual que cero para que el cambio en la
entropía sea mayor o igual que cero ok
así que cuando tomamos por ejemplo una
clase de química introductoria el
maestro generalmente dice que la
entropía es igual al disco 'la al
desorden
quien no es incorrecto es si es desorden
pero tenemos que tener cuidado con lo
que entendemos por desorden porque el
siguiente ejemplo que es el que
generalmente se dan en las clases es por
ejemplo un cuarto limpio una habitación
limpia o que hay una habitación limpia y
después se convierte en una habitación
sucia bueno el universo a lo mejor tiene
más desorden en él en la habitación
sucia pero no es un caso correcto de
entropía de aumento de entropía no es un
buen ejemplo
no es un buen ejemplo y eso porque bueno
porque cuando tenemos un cuarto limpio o
sucio es que tenemos que fijarnos
realmente en la variable macro en la
macro variable la entropía es una
variable de estado
macro ok y la entropía de hecho nos dice
cuánto tiempo por ejemplo me me lleva a
decir lo que cuánto tiempo me lleva a
decir cómo se comporta una partícula de
hecho nos dice cuántos estados hay
cuánta información posee este sistema
ahora cuando tenemos un cuarto limpio
tenemos dos distintos estados del mismo
cuarto por ejemplo si tenemos la
temperatura si tenemos la misma
temperatura y el mismo número de
moléculas esencialmente tienen la misma
entropía así que un cuarto succión no no
es que tenga más entropía por ejemplo
puedes tener un cuarto sucio y que esté
frío ok entonces un cuarto sucio y frío
podríamos decir entonces
que entramos y empezamos a limpiarlo y
nos esmeramos mucho y empezamos a sudar
y hacemos generamos calor con todo el
trabajo que realizamos por limpiar
nuestro cuerpo entonces eso nos lleva a
un cuarto más caliente
y limpio y que además a lo mejor tiene
sudor no lo que yo despedí mientras
trabajaba entonces en este sentido
debido a que está más caliente y además
hay más moléculas eso me da más estados
ok la energía es más grande y entonces
las posibilidades de estado de las
partículas en este cuarto tienen mayores
opciones y por lo tanto aquí hay un
incremento en la en la entropía no de un
cuarto que está sucio a uno que está
limpio y de hecho esto cuando cuando
empezamos a limpiar el cuarto estoy
generando calor en dentro de él y el
universo se está volviendo está
incrementando la entropía hay más
estados así que de dónde viene este eco
o cómo entendemos la palabra desorden en
un sistema vamos a pensar en una
situación donde tengo por ejemplo una
pelota
ok y digamos que cae al suelo aunque ya
aquí golpea el suelo qué
aquí por ejemplo podríamos pensar que
ocurre con la energía aunque debido
debido a la primera ley de la
termodinámica cuando el la pelota cae al
suelo viene con muchísima energía
cinética llegue al suelo y de repente se
detiene ok entonces la pregunta obvia es
qué pasa con esa energía la ley de la
conservación de la energía me está
diciendo que se tiene que ir a algún
lado verdad si golpe al suelo y después
desaparece en realidad no es que
desaparezca cuando la pelota va cayendo
tenía ya sabes un montón de calor que
estaba más o menos el orden del suelo el
suelo estaba muy ordenado digamos las
moléculas de ahí están vibrando tenían
cierta energía kinética cinética y
potencial y después nuestras moléculas
de la pelota que están alomejor vibrando
pero esencialmente lo que tienen es una
emoción un movimiento hacia abajo verdad
entonces cuando golpee el suelo lo que
ocurre y déjenme mostrarles digamos lo
que ocurre a nivel micro en la pelota
así que aquí están las moléculas de la
pelota que se ven
o menos así que digamos esto es un
sólido pueden a lo mejor estar
arreglados como en una latina y después
golpean las moléculas del suelo que aquí
está el suelo es otro sólido digamos que
se ve así que así se ven sus moléculas y
estamos viendo el micro estado de este
fenómeno éstos amarillitos de la pelota
empiezan a transferir el calor o la
energía cinética ok hacia abajo y la
transfieren a las partículas del suelo
entonces empiezan a rebotar todas las
partículas del suelo perdón entonces a
lo mejor estos empiezan a rebotar los de
las pelotas quién sabe empiezan a
moverse a lo mejor oscilan a lo mejor
éste podría rebotar en dirección los de
la pelota podrían regresar
no sabemos ok pero empiezan empiezan a
rebotar y a rebotar y generan como una
especie de efecto en cadena entonces lo
que tenemos era esencialmente un
movimiento ordenado de digamos desde el
punto de vista de la pelota que al
chocar con las moléculas del suelo
empieza a hacer que la energía zinc
y su movimiento empieza a hacer empieza
a recorrerse en direcciones medio
aleatorias en ese sentido así que cuando
el movimiento ya no es ordenado si
tenemos un montón de moléculas déjenme
hacerlo con otro color
tenemos un muy un montón de moléculas
que se mueven en una misma dirección a
nivel micro bueno a nivel micro se ve
por ejemplo con el ejemplo que hicimos
de la pelota ok pero cuando se mueven a
distintas direcciones muy aleatorias en
realidad tenemos el mismo número de
energía cinética a nivel molecular pero
están rebotando entre ellas están
rebotando más de forma más rara en este
caso describimos que la energía cinética
está descrita por digamos la temperatura
que describe el promedio de la energía
cinética en este caso cuando hablamos
que el mundo se vuelve más desordenado
estamos pensando en el orden de las
velocidades y de la energía de las
moléculas antes de que las moléculas
estuvieran realmente ordenadas a lo
mejor realmente iban todas hacia abajo
esencialmente pero cuando chocan con el
suelo empiezan a vibrar de forma en
direcciones aleatorias y hacen que el
suelo también vibre de forma muy rara
entonces hace al menos a nivel micro que
se vuelva muy desordenado ahora hay una
pregunta interesante aquí digamos habrá
alguna probabilidad pensemos si tubieran
es esta pelota que viene hacia el suelo
porque no la pelota o más bien habrá una
probabilidad de que si yo tengo una
pelota y él y el suelo que estas
moléculas empiecen a arreglar justo en
de tal forma que empiezan a golpear las
moléculas de la pelota
de esta forma así que habrá alguna
probabilidad solo por el movimiento
aleatorio de que en algún momento las
moléculas del suelo golpeen a la pelota
para mandarla hacia arriba y la
respuesta es sí de hecho hay una una
pequeña e infinita décima probabilidad
de que eso ocurra verdad venderías por
ejemplo esto es bastante interesante
aquí tienes el suelo y una pelota que
está en el suelo a lo mejor tendría que
esperar un millón de años o millones de
billones de años para ver que la pelota
de repente bote hacia arriba de la nada
y hay una probabilidad muy pequeña de
que la vibración de estas moléculas se
ordenen de tal manera que lancen la
pelota hacia arriba pero la probabilidad
de este evento es relativamente es
esencialmente cero entonces cuando la
gente habla de orden y liso y desorden
el desorden es y está incrementando
están moviéndose en direcciones más
aleatoria
en mayo tiene mayores estados
potenciales y sabemos hasta cierto nivel
que la entropía ya no es algo mágico
al menos más bien ya aparece como
sentido común en este vídeo donde en el
último vídeo donde vimos que si teníamos
un montón de moléculas y después
poníamos un espacio extra y de repente
vaporiza vamos la pared y vimos que
estas moléculas estas moléculas bueno
sabemos que siempre van a empezar
si están golpeando en las paredes y
generando cierta presión entonces al
mover la pared éstas empiezan a seguirse
ya ya no chocan con el muro porque ya no
existe y no se detienen es decir se
siguen moviendo
las direcciones y abarcan hacia la
dirección en donde tenemos la nueva la
nueva el nuevo volumen digamos y así que
estos se van a expandir hacia todo el
contenedor y esto es bastante de sentido
común pero la cosa bonita que vimos en
ese vídeo también nos dice que esto va a
ocurrir que las moléculas se van a
expandir para llenar todo el contenedor
y que todo esto todo esto está
ocurriendo a lo mejor iba a llegar un
momento en el que todos regresen a la
mía la posición original según lo que
vimos en este vídeo van a regresar todas
hacia el lado izquierdo pero hay una
probabilidad muy muy pequeña y quiero
hacer esto muy claro ese es un macro
estado macro estado nunca hablamos de la
entropía para moléculas individuales
sabemos lo que una molécula
individualmente está haciendo no
deberíamos preocuparnos por la entropía
solo esto lo vamos a hablar como la
entropía es un estado del sistema y
cuando estamos mirando el sistema si no
estamos mirando directamente a las
de hecho no sabemos qué es lo que está
pasando con las moléculas todo lo que
podemos hacer es mirar las propiedades
estadísticas de estas pero por ejemplo
cuántas moléculas hay y su dinámica pero
una caja que tiene estas moléculas tiene
un estado que que un mayor es un mayor
número de estados que una caja más
pequeña baja entonces no tendríamos que
saber realmente lo que pasó con cada una
de las moléculas esto es muy importante
de entender cuando alguien habla por
ejemplo de un cuarto sucio o de un
cuarto limpio están mirando los
microestados del sistema la entropía
esencialmente es una un macro estado
cierta cantidad de energía la posee un
sistema así que la entropía asociada con
el cuarto por ejemplo sólo es útil
cuando no estás cuando no sabes lo que
está pasando en el cuarto digo sabemos
la temperatura del cuarto la presión del
cuarto el volumen del cuarto porque son
propiedades macro y la entropía
esencialmente nos dice cuántas cuántos
micro estados posibles puede
el sistema tener o cuánta información y
de ahí hay una noción de entropía de
información cuánta información tiene
tenemos tienes que darme para saber el
estado micro exacto del sistema como sea
espero que hayan entendido este vídeo
que clarifique los los conceptos de
entropía y les dé más intuición sobre lo
que de hecho es nos vemos